earlier this evening several commercials
ago but a week and a half mr. Robert
Goulet sang the five nominated songs by
popular demand of the songwriters and
you excuse the expression music lovers
everywhere now the moment is at hand
when the winning song is to be announced
and to make that announcement Arthur
freed our producers assigned a very
sweet fellow the nominees are every
Mancini and Johnny verse with four days
of wine and roses Bronislaw caper and
Paul Francis Webster for a love song for
mutiny on the body follow me Andre
Previn and Dory Langdon for song four
from two for the seesaw second chance
Sammy fain and Paul Francis Webster for
Tender is the night Elmer Bernstein Mark
David McDavid scuse me for a walk on the
wild side may I have the lead sheet mr.
Miller oh it feels so dandy the winners
are Harry Henry Mancini and Johnny
Mercer four days of wine and roses
ladies and gentlemen course mr. Dowson
gave me a beautiful title and mr.
Mancini gave me a beautiful tune but I'm
grateful anyway thank you very much I'd
like to thank the Academy my old friend
Blake Edwards my new friend Martin
Magnus the producer and my huckleberry
friend Sonia Mercer thank you